one of the things that some Republicans
have realized they've come to understand
this is that they have sort of lost
control of the monster they created and
thought would be a great thing for them
and that monster is the trumpists in the
Republican Party
Kevin McCarthy caught on audio we now
know we talked about it earlier in the
show back in January of 2021 saying we
Trump should resign Trump should resign
he realized that they lost control they
were going to ride the monster oh look
at the they're gonna vote they're voting
for Trump I guess I guess we're going to
have a Republican president there let's
go with it they're willing to vote for
Trump
and then they became a monster they lost
control of and they rioted on January
6th and the rest is sort of History
we've also seen them lose control of the
monster when it comes to vaccines and
Donald Trump recently gave a speech on
Amelia uh in in on Amelia Island in
Florida
and he wanted to praise the vaccine and
take credit for it but he knows that his
base might crush him and he acknowledges
sometimes people get angry when I talk
about the vaccine my greatest
achievements was getting the vaccine
done in nine months instead of five and
a half to 12 years but the problem is
you know we saved tens of billions of
lives all over the world but I can't
talk about it because our base our
beautiful base of which some of you are
there you get angry when we mention the
word vaccine don't get it true we did it
in nine months less than nine months
right less than nine months Trump wants
his base to be skeptical of science when
it's politically inconvenient whatever
it might be masks public safety
guidelines whatever don't take unproven
stuff for covid but when it's to his
benefit he wants them to believe in that
very science that he has primed them not
to believe believe in science when it
makes me look good and this is not a new
thing Trump knows he's ruined his own
base back in August of 2021 Trump
actually got booed when he talked about
the vaccine and how great it is three
days less than nine months and it's
great and you know what I believe
totally in your freedoms I do free you
got to do what you have to do but
I recommend taking the vaccines I did it
it's good take the vaccines but you got
no that's okay oh
you got your free
but I happen to take the vaccine if it
doesn't work you'll be the first to know
okay
I'll call up Alabama say hey you know
what
but it's so regularly getting booed then
he did this weird thing with Bill
O'Reilly where there were often unsold
seats and they both said they got the
vaccine and people didn't like it both
the president and I are backs and uh did
you get the booster
yes I got it too okay so um
that's a very tiny group of trump
wanting to minimize the booing but it
was certainly there and then lastly uh
from this very strange speech just one
this is just funny because of what it
points to for the next few years here's
how Trump says we're going to unite the
country the one that we have the path
back to American Unity is not to
surrender the culture wars the path back
to National Unity is to decisively win
the culture wars now of course the idea
that you're going to unite the country
by winning imaginary culture wars that
you created in order to divide the
country is absurd it is absurd but I
don't think Republicans have any other
idea so if I had to guess in 22 and in
24
their platform will be now we're not
going to fix climate we're not going to
fix health care we're not going to fix
immigration we're not going to fix taxes
we're not going to fix anything we're
just going to win imaginary culture wars
that we created and then say hey we put
out a fire we started sort of except
it's still on fire and you should vote
for us thanks to that they're telling us
what the strategy will be and I believe
them